マイネ肇社長菖蒲とって生きる
はーいうわぁ遠くリーグレーチェ
なぁおおおおっ今日始めそうです今日はですねちょっととある実験的なことをしようと
思います皆様 iphone 使ってますでしょうか真ん中のホームボタンを長押し
すると siri 書
移動します
ためよ英語か常々今回の実験で必要なのは尻を英語の設定にすることです
設定の一般から指令が設定で普通に英語にできると思います今回ちょっと情報を
いただいたんですけども
3の設定を英語にしてガール女の子っていいですね
ガールと発音してみて下さい共がお腹詳しいこと
わからないんですけども英語を設定してガールチーンに言ってしりがあるって認識して
くれたらなんかすごい見たい何がすごいか分からないんですけどもなかなかちょっとな
んだ日本じゃば髪が発音が難しいに当てガールってもう留学でちょっと英語を勉強した
んですけども掃除機があれば難しい
r と l の発音がね違うこれがある
l は
んーなんかこうしたおねえあーこれガーン
ああこれがえっええ
これ
俺もよくわかんないんだごめんなさい明確一定だけど正直よくわかんないよまず難しい
ことは事実です
中国していた外国の友達の中で r って言ってたいと思いました
ギャルじゃねえかけてガールの発音が凄い難しいのでそれがなんか関係してるのかなと
か勝手に思ってますね持参しちゃうとかだけ金が実際にこのイギリスガールのルーク
シュシュ肇社長が siri のガールの初
完全にリンチします今回それとその僕の英語の発音の素晴らしさを皆さんに見せつけれ
ばいいなと思っておりますよ行こう
ガー
ana 社員でしたそれ銘苅じゃあわかんないねっ
ゲーム
いや twitter いやぁあえあーなんて誰も言ってねー奴なんてこれ難しいぞ
ギャー
通院再開価値は間に p 3クリックターフオーナー re the year
ok i さんですちょっとねじゃあ
いい時間ヨカーン
今回ありがとうございますガー ok
サイパンバーン
ガー team as one さあ魚ズザーってこれ本当の強カード
カーチャはっはっかりとガッツだね4群ある
ana 者にもそういやガールでリアでも今の髪であってたんですか結構ふざけました
よ通ったけど今のが正しい発音今通じてました今のでいいのややおかしい c 分発の
ちょっとちょっと今が信憑性がないのでもう1回やってみましょう
ルー
パターンいうアート失点を p 同社の基本形どらーん
アナちゃんとしてこれどうんのか
やっぱちょっとふざけたどれがいいですねー5ドアは記者 by google じゃ
ねーわ
ガー
冷やしたなく実4 r は米強くつがカーってロール派のるう動きが大事ですよく
わかんないけどねでも統一通るぞ
一応発音がなんかできてるんだようわぁ
ana 社員として google ホットって+
るーっ
いいからも打っドーン苦手だ言ってみれば
ガーン
うそーん
じゃあこれ本当ねあの難しいですよ
チームですこれ艦舌が悪いからそもそも日本語英語わかんねーがー
東誰だって俺これさあこれ英語の発音の練習になるよガールの発音がちゃんとできてる
とわかるから俺すごいなんといいことして何況あるファイルの発音がちゃんとできる
ようにな
んがぁああああああああああああ
グルーン ok
well 間部みー
ますちゃスピーカーズ ok no なお徒歩さああなたに必要なのははい
そして iphone
持った
た
ていた
e 7